Justin Bieber makes a surprise
appearance at Craig David's concert and
hangs with a mystery woman there's
Bieber wrapping his arm around a mystery
blonde during Craig David's concert at
the Roxy in LA on Tuesday an eye witness
tells et he spent most of the night
dancing and hanging out with her amid
rumors he and on-and-off girlfriend
Selena Gomez are taking some time apart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
during the concert David sang his tracks
16 which samples Bieber's hit where are
you now
Bieber hopped up on stage to share some
kind words earlier in the day David
stopped by et to promote his latest
album the time is now he praised Bieber
as a musician and person would you ever
want to collab with someone like ariana
grande or Justin Bieber yeah of course I
mean I've watched Justin grow into into
the young man that he is now and like
it's incredible to see him be able to to
own it in the way that he is because I
think a lot of us tried to kind
understand how someone could actually be
in the spotlight like he's been and we
have to hold it together and come with
the music and still kind of keep it
relevant and keep it fresh person the
studio and make happy
[Music]
[Applause]